no matter how it all goes down I've got
your back everything okay
we're Sasha Rosita go got your points
all right
they need you
[Music]
hey youtubers it's Charlie this is going
to be my Walking Dead episode 14 video I
gave the spoiler warning earlier at the
beginning of the video so here we go
there's a new round of the giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
so we got to talk about what's going on
with Sasha it seems that she's totally
throwing herself under the bus and with
two episodes to go you do have to wonder
if she's not going to make it to the
next season especially when you consider
the stuff that's going on behind the
scenes so I'll talk about that in a
second because in real life the actress
is doing something else that's pretty
breaking big this year and a lot of
people are like hey AMC are you totally
spoiling what's going to happen to her
character and they're like no no no
she's going to be able to do all these
things at the same time don't worry so
some of you probably know what I'm
talking about
but their art was the really important
one during this episode even though all
the plot threads were really important
because their ting up some really big
stuff with Gregory but I just wanted to
focus on that I still wanted to do my
top ten but their storyline was so much
better than everything else that I felt
like it was important to focus on that
just a really badass scenes with the
women of Abraham I loved the way they
talked around him - where'd you learn
all this army stuff yeah I knew a guy
but then you learned what a badass
Rosita is and how she would just move
from boyfriend a boyfriend til she
learned everything she could then she
would move on to a new Jedi Master and
even though Daryl showed up at the end
so you're like oh you know maybe
somebody will be there to help her out
and he is out for blood who's going to
kill negan first it almost seems like
Sasha's reset Zen Jedi state where she's
completely ready to die so she's going
to become this force ghost in their
version of the Death Star fight between
obi-wan and Darth Vader strike me down
and I'll become more powerful than you
could ever imagine but given all this
build up the crazy thing is I don't
think that negan has a chance of dying
this season they might wound him I think
that Lucille might die this season but I
think that negan is going to crawl away
to fight another day
because he's just too interesting of a
character to get rid of in no comic book
spoilers but there's a whole bunch of
comic book stuff that we could talk
about if you have read the comic book
and you know all about the characters
please just use spoiler tags in the
comments just because I do think that
they will be sticking very close to the
comic book storyline with at least most
of the major characters I think there'll
be a couple twists and the really
exciting things that you guys will be
really happy about is they said that
they're not going to do the cliffhanger
ending before season 8 they will end and
they'll be like a final moment you'll
get a resolution it won't be like a did
they kill this person did they not kill
this person type of endings it'll just
have everybody throwing their monitors
across their room next we got to talk
about Gregory
he's a total [ __ ] even if you didn't
watch the teaser for the next episode
you know that you're supposed to hate it
that was the whole point of this episode
oh he's got that look on his face he's
getting ready to crap his pants he's
trying to break jesus's band up Maggie
seems to be hyper organized everybody
loves her there's just so many things
pointing towards the coup and he's back
dealing with Simon here our grand theft
auto Trevor whatever you want to call
him but just to explain that twist with
Simon so when he made the deal it was so
that he would be able to get into the
sanctuary to hang out with Simon in chat
about anything they might want to chat
about so what would Gregory want to chat
about in the next couple of episodes he
senses something is coming
so it seems like they're just
telegraphing him ratting out everyone
that's plotting against negan will share
some tequila in a surprise surprise at
the end of the episode as he's given the
business to Jesus somebody brings in
some tequila like he's a tequila man now
saying that he is a savior just like
Eugene big Eugene twists he is now on
Rosita's hitless but I think what's
happening in this scene here is that
even though he's refusing to leave he
hasn't gone full Savior yet there will
still be some sort of twist where he
redeems himself it's just that he's so
much of a coward that in his surprise
he's completely frozen deer in the
headlights so he doesn't have time to
think about it he will probably be
presented with another opportunity to
redeem himself but he just needs that
push to find his courage and hopefully
Sasha will be that courage like he'll
see her sacrifice that is how her
character goes down some of the other
characters on The Walking Dead have arcs
like that even Rick Grimes is like that
where he sees other people sacrifice
themselves and he's like I realized we
can't go on living like this usually
Michonne is a person that inspires Rick
but for a person like Morgan that moment
came after Benjamin that that pushed him
over the edge so Eugene just needs
something to push him over that edge let
me know in the comments though what do
you think is going to go down in the
finale because the way I see the next
episode is just sort of like a really
long finale stretched out over two
episodes that's kind of what they've
done this season is the way they weed
the episodes together like we got a
prelude at the beginning of this episode
the opening ten minutes of the episode
took place before Rosita showed up so
this is one of the ways that they get
through a season of Walking Dead or a
half season and only a week or so has
gone by on the show I think next season
they might move away from that a little
bit I think they're listening to fans
response like oh hey you know these big
event cliffhanger episodes they're great
or what about all the builder episodes
in between I think there's been a lot of
great character work but I think people
have just come to expect a certain level
of craziness from the Walking Dead
so when they don't get it it just seems
really weird like hey this is the
walking that we tuned in for walkers we
turned in for crazy action what's going
on here so it'll be fun to address that
in the next season but Maggie taking
over Sasha throwing yourself under the
bus maybe Rosita and Daryl can help out
and Eugene hopefully Eugene comes around
but there were a whole bunch of
characters that we did not see in this
episode like Dwight Dwight seems like a
very important piece of the negan puzzle
and he wasn't anywhere in this episode
so it seems like what they're doing is
they're just setting up all the
character arcs for the big twist of the
finale but let me know in the comments
how do you think it's all going to go
down I feel like it's going to be a
great finale but there were a couple
episodes where it did feel like just
absolutely nothing happened this season
so hopefully that does not repeat next
season but what's going to happen next
is there's more Marvel DC coming up so
I'll post that as quick as possible
congratulations - Nuno Sylva please
private message me on the back end of my
channel there was a new round that
started in this video I'll announce the
winners the next time I post a Walking
Dead video while you wait for that click
here for Black Panther movie behind the
scenes and you can click here for my
Iron Fist review thank you so much for
watching
let's have BOTS I'll see you guys in the
next video
you